If you’re in a theater during previews,
and you see this ….
… you know to expect a comedy movie.
If you see this — you know it’s going
to be action.
Make the letters a little skinny — and boom.
It’s sci-fi.
You know this one's going to have fast
cars...
This one’s going to have Michael Cera….
… and this one’s gonna be a rom-com.
You don’t even need the music to know it.
But what about this?
This typeface — Trajan – is probably one
of the most popular movie poster fonts ever.
You can see it in Crouching Tiger, Hidden
Dragon, Double Jeopardy, Letters from Iwo Jima,
It’s everywhere.
So how did it get there?
I'm Yves Peters, I am a graphic designer who
has been writing professionally about type
and typography since about 10 years.
Yves has looked at a lot of posters.
And a few years ago, he started to notice
a trend.
I started clicking, clicking, clicking, and
didn't know where I started because I ended
up looking at about 16,000 posters.
Yeah.
Well I look at about 100 posters per month and
I've been doing this series since 2006…
It’s a lot of posters every year.
He noticed that the use of Trajan rose significantly
in the last couple of decades.
But why?
In 1989, designer Carol Twombly adapted inscriptions
from Roman emperor Trajan’s column into
a digital typeface.
It was made for Adobe, so it was a part of
the software that a lot of people were starting
to use to make posters.
A couple years later, it made its movie poster
debut here — for Héctor Babenco’s
At Play in the Fields of the Lord.
After that, it was on The Bodyguard, and Scent
of a Woman.
Then it was on three 1993 box office hits.
By 1994, it was everywhere.
It's originally used for epic movies, movies
about people that overcome difficulties, like
the big war epics and so on.
But then you see gradually that it becomes
the standard movie font.
It's like the Arial of movie posters.
So people need to churn out a poster really
quickly, and they just pick Trajan.
Eventually, that overuse changed the kinds
of movies that used the typeface.
You don’t see it as much on the big productions
anymore.
It's become the typeface of horror movies,
B-movies, and also the straight-to-video ones.
So you'll see that a lot of posters are for
the lesser movies that want to pretend they
are better than they actually are.
The rise and fall of Trajan illustrates the
downside of digital typeface.
The convenience of swapping fonts is a huge
shift from old movie poster days when hand-painted
typefaces or "lettering" was an art that was
specific to each movie.
So what you see behind me — this is more
like the pre-blockbuster thing...
pre-genres, pre-standard styles — and
that's why you will be hard pressed to find
two that are similar.
That doesn’t make today’s genre-specific
typography bad design.
These visual clichés make it possible to
communicate tone and plot details to an audience
incredibly efficiently.
And there’s a certain art to that.
People get nostalgic about the old era of
movie posters, when everything was still done
by hand and still very unique.
But you could compare it to music, where some
people say, “nothing good was produced since
the Beatles.”
But then there are people who say there’s
nothing good since Mozart.
Fair enough, but there's many other interesting
things that are being produced now.
There’s just much more.
But there's still a lot of very good poster
design happening.
It’s just, you need to know where to look.”